Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson has
been fired by Fox News what was
initially reported as they have parted
ways is very clearly a firing as far as
we know as of uh Tucker's last show on
Friday he expected to be back on the air
last night we have
four different potential reasons that
may have played a role in what took
place and I will tell you about all of
them but do not be confused this is a
firing we have a report from The
Washington Post Tucker Carlson is out at
Fox News after dominion lawsuit
disclosures this is potentially one
element of the firing which is that the
discovery
from the Dominion lawsuit against Fox
News which led to a settlement of 787.5
million dollars in favor of dominion
included the release of text messages
from Tucker Carlson some of which
contained Tucker saying he hates Trump
passionately which is interesting but
also text messages in which Tucker
Carlson was criticizing Fox management
that's not a great thing if you were Fox
News and now you've got to deal with
this guy we also have this lawsuit that
is forthcoming related to harassment
taking place within the walls of the
Tucker Carlson production uh apparatus I
guess we would call it a woman has filed
a lawsuit and makes all sorts of very
very tough allegations and that is a
mess for Fox News as well in addition to
this we have potentially a forthcoming
lawsuit from Ray Epps Ray Epps is this
guy who was in Washington DC on January
5th 2021
and many people including Tucker Carlson
have made ray Epps's life a living hell
signal boosting conspiracy theories that
Ray Epps is some kind of agent
provocateur or FBI informant or whatever
the case may be who was trying to entrap
rioters by encouraging to them to go and
Riot when they had no plan to do so
there's no evidence of any of that and
there was a 60 Minutes piece on Sunday
just two days ago in which Ray Epps
specifically points to Tucker Carlson
and saying essentially he's made my life
a living hell that is also a lawsuit
concerned so when you step back and you
think about it Tucker Carlson
responsible to some degree for giving
voice to those conspiracies that led to
the 787 million dollar settlement for
Dominion in addition to that that very
lawsuit releasing text messages from
Tucker Carlson that make it a little
awkward to have them working for you
you've got one lawsuit already with
another lawsuit essentially forthcoming
as good as his ratings were this guy is
really a headache for you and we have
video this was the end of Tucker what
ended up being Tucker Carlson's final
episode on Friday he says I'll be back
Monday and there is every indication
that he believed he would be back on the
air yesterday
segment and
you came on and I'm especially grateful
for the pie thank you for having me
appreciate it employee of the week we're
going to orders make it of the Year
Tyler morale of Coco's Pizza that's it
for us for the week we'll be back by the
way the entire episode of let them eat
bugs not quite as good as Pizza
streaming now on Fox Nation is a promo
code Originals for 30 days free and
we'll be back on Monday in the meantime
have the best weekend with the ones that
you love there it is we'll be back on
Monday so every indication that he would
be back so listen let's think through
the larger implications here will Tucker
ultimately be replaced with someone
worse it's possible last night Brian
Kilmeade from Fox and Friends filled in
for Tucker and we'll have a few seconds
of that it was pretty awkward a little
bit later in the show imagine the bigger
picture though Tucker Carlson was
reportedly fired by Fox at least in part
for the things he said about Fox
management as revealed in the Dominion
lawsuit so in some incredible way
Trump's hair brained election lies which
led to the attacks on minion which led
to the lawsuit led to Tucker's firing in
a sense Tucker's firing came
from the big lie about the 2020 election
in terms of whether it's good for the
country to have Tucker off the air what
will likely be temporarily because
Tucker is going to find something else
of course Tucker broke the brains of
millions of people
he was seen by many on the right as a
real thinker which is hilarious and so
in some sense the country is better off
with Tucker not spouting propaganda on
the other hand he'll find some other
place to do it it just won't be Fox
additionally Don Lemon was fired from
CNN yesterday that relates to what
happened with Tucker in some ways we'll
delve into that in more detail on the
bonus show later today so let's take a
quick break make sure you're subscribed
on the YouTube channel if you're just
listening today you can watch I know
it's crazy to think there's a video
component to this insane show that we do
every day but there is you can watch at
youtube.com the davidpackman show we're
going to take a quick break let emotions
simmer on set and then we'll be back
with much more in a moment if you deal
with anxiety or depression you may have
tried meditation exercise diet changes
therapy all of which are important
things to try there is also a new
treatment that we've been talking about
on the program for years which for many
people has been a game changer and that
is ketamine therapy the research around
ketamine therapy for anxiety and
depression looks very promising which is
why I'm thrilled about our new sponsor
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people with anxiety
and depression it's delivered to your
door it's done from the comfort of your
home and unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improve movements in their
anxiety and depression after just two
sessions read about the evidence for
ketamine therapy we've talked about it
on the show it's pretty remarkable stuff
mind Bloom is offering my audience a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description